[Music]
this man you see on the screen reject
tayap erdogan has been Lord and Master
of Turkish politics for the last 20
years and now to the Chagrin of
virtually the entire Western Bloc he has
won at the polls again after surviving
an obscure and bizarre coup d'etat
ramming through a constitution and
implementing a bizarre economic policy
that has hit the country hard and
wrecked the value of the Lira Turks are
still betting on erwan under his
leadership turkey has gone from being a
tolerant Islamic democracy an example of
moderation to become an increasingly
uncomfortable partner for both the
European Union and nato in fact many
consider that we are on the verge of a
new autocracy right at the gates of
Europe for others we are witnessing
turkey's definitive break with the West
be that as it mean we are talking about
a candidate who has been seen handing
out wads of money at the doors of his
polling station on Election Day itself
but how did we get here and what does it
all mean how did this Turkish neo-sultan
come into being what is he after why did
he still manage to win in the latest
election well we're going to answer all
these questions but first let's get an
overview of the situation with some
history check this out
[Applause]
[Music]
the
Ottoman Empire participated in the first
world war along with Germany the
austro-hungarian Empire and Bulgaria and
what would be the last great action of
this Empire at least under that same
denomination in 1918 they were on the
losing side so the Victorious allies
were then able to force the then Sultan
Mehmet VI to sign the Treaty of severe
this treaty confirmed the surrender of
the Ottoman Empire and meant the
division of its territories outside
turkey it also provided for
international control of the city of
Istanbul and the Bosphorus and
Dardanelle Straits the creation of a
large new independent Armenian nation in
eastern Anatolia and a buffer zone for
the Kurds who would be free to choose
Independence after a period of autonomy
however this treaty was never ratified
by the ottoman government due to Turkish
resistance led by Mustafa Kamal Ataturk
who led the so-called Turkish War of
Independence
as a result of this war the Treaty of
severe was replaced by the Treaty of
Luzan in 1923 which established the
modern borders of the Republic of turkey
and annulled many of the provisions of
the Treaty of severe later the second
world war was already a clear sign of
what would become from then on the
double face of Turkish foreign policy
you see while the country signed a
protection agreement with France and the
United Kingdom in 1939 the successes of
the German Blitzkrieg LED Ankara to also
sign a friendship treaty with the Third
Reich around 1941. the result the
Turkish Armed Forces ended up being
equipped with both Allied and axis
technology but yes in 1945 the Turks
definitely went over to the Allies it
was not a particularly loyal possession
but the Advent of the Cold War meant
that all of this back and forth was
basically forgotten overnight
competition with the Soviets prompted
the White House to step up to the plate
and sign a comprehensive security treaty
with turkey which resulted in the
Deliverance of large-scale military aid
since 1947.
[Music]
and so this is how the special
relationship between Washington and
Ankara and by extension turkey's
relationship with the entire Western
world came about thus the Turkish
government signed its integration with
the West joining the Council of Europe
in 1949 nato in 1952 and the oecd in
1961. however turkey was a country full
of tensions externally the deployment of
U.S Jupiter nuclear missiles on its
territory aimed directly at the Soviet
Union put the country at the epicenter
of political debate throughout the Cold
War on the other hand internally many
politicians little by little were trying
to implement a much more religious model
for the country this was only stopped by
the pressure of the Armed Forces for
decades the Turkish Army was something
of a shield against the growing
islamization of the country although
even this mechanism did not always work
in the most desirable way we are talking
about two kudi's Tas one in 1960 and the
other in 1918.
and that is not all for decades the
country was also immersed in a great tug
of war between State planning and market
capitalism essentially between the end
of the second World War and the 1980s
planning policies and control of the
economy predominated so did
protectionism to supposedly support
domestic Industries it was only from the
1980s onwards that the country turned to
the open market and capitalism
and visual party viewers let there be no
doubt about it turkey's geographical
position as a Nexus a point of Union
between Asia Europe and the Middle East
was absolutely crucial to this whole
process for this reason Western
institutions tried to integrate turkey
more and more for a time it even seemed
reasonably close to joining the European
Union itself well that was basically the
country where erdogan grew up and
evolved a country halfway between East
and West between secularization and
religiosity between capitalism and
economic planning and so it was until
the coming to power of erdogan himself
the man who has practically refounded
the country during the first two decades
of the 21st century listen up
yeah
soccer Islam and Military pressures
foreign
1971 the Turkish Armed Forces issued an
ultimatum to the conservative government
of Suleiman de Mariel and in general all
political parties the military demanded
that the politicians contained the
glowing religious extremism that was
bearing chaos to the Republican order
this situation worsened after the onset
of a severe economic crisis caused in
large part by strong trade protectionism
the fact is that the crisis resulted in
high levels of unemployment over 20 and
out of control inflation for example
while annual inflation was 15.4 in 1972
by 1980 it was already over 94 well at
that time the government ordered the
illegalization of several parties for
being against secularization that is to
say against the model of a
non-denominational State among those
banned formations was the national order
party the mnp in which erdogan was a
militant however the following year the
leader of this party Nick metin airbagan
registered another similar grouping
under the name of the national salvation
party MSP remember this name because it
will be key in the future of the still
young erdogan visual politic viewers the
turbulent 1970s finally ended with a
coup d'etat in 1980. that year the
military Junta leaded by General Kennan
Evron seized Democratic institutions
extended martial law banned all
political parties and imprisoned and
tried tens of thousands of political
activists during this time with politics
firmly shut down erdogan explored other
fields for example he tried his luck as
a semi-professional footballer and
managed to earn a University's degree in
Business Administration
[Applause]
the fact is that in 1983 under the cover
of the military's new permissive
legislation the national salvation party
was refounded into the welfare party and
under arabican's command erdogan once
again jumped back into Political life
his big break would come in 1984. that
year a democratically elected government
returned to power and just then erdogan
began to gain political influence in the
opposition he was appointed coordinator
of the welfare party in Istanbul
Province his name little by little began
to become popular he represented the
only islamist force with influence in
the country's urban districts
and so in 1994 with 25.2 percent of the
vote erdogan became the new mayor of
Istanbul keep in mind this was an
absolutely key moment an islamist party
had taken control of the main city in
all of turkey the question the country
was asking itself was what would this
government look like with the islamists
put an end to secularism could they end
up provoking a new coup d'etat well the
truth is the erdogan knew how to play
his cards it was the perfect occasion to
show that his islamist party could be a
force of majorities and as we say around
here no sooner said than done
thank you
to the surprise of many this mayor gave
preference to management over religion
for example he promoted a plan of Public
Works and new technologies to solve the
problems that existed in the Water
Service in the congested Road Network
and in the waste system infrastructure
and Public Works were clearly his
Hallmark and his springboard to National
politics suddenly the welfare party
seemed to have put aside its islamist
agenda to become the standard Bearer for
modernization in the cities and guess
what in 1989 this Evolution allowed them
to become the most voted Force at the
national level in the general elections
however they were unable to form a
government the military opposed them
head-on and asked the other two major
political parties the motherland party
and the true path party to reach a
government pact and veto the islamists
moderate or not the military did not
want to see them represented even in the
slightest in running National politics
however this pact lasted barely a year
and on the 28th of June 1996 Nissan
erkaban the founder of the country's
only major islamist political force
succeeded in becoming prime minister and
no don't think he followed erdogan's
path of moderation
arbican wanted to push a forward a much
more islamist agenda among his main
points was closer ties with countries
like Libya and Iran something that was
too much for the military which forced
him to resign in 1987. shortly
thereafter the Constitutional court
itself outlawed the welfare party for
carrying out activities contrary to the
secularism of the state and that was not
all the legal authorities also convicted
erdogan himself for inciting religious
hatred specifically he was accused of
having used the following verses of the
poet and nationalist ideologue ziago Kai
as a proclamation at the political rally
take note because it is not mintz's
words it was a clear manifestation of
intentions The Masks are our Barracks
the domes our helmets the minarets our
bayonets and the Believers our soldiers
erdogan was dismissed from the mayor's
office and sentenced to 10 months in
prison but wait a minute convicted for
reciting some verses well we've already
told you that the religious question was
a very sensitive topic within the
country the thing is that we could all
imagine that after being impeached and
imprisoned erdogan's political career
would have come to an end but you can
see that it did not the question is what
did he do to relaunch himself likewise
to re-establish his name attain power
and gain such large majorities well
we're going to take a look at that right
now
recep tape 2.0
when erdogan regained his freedom he was
completely banned from political life
there was no possibility of becoming a
candidate or to form a political party
the question was did he really have to
take on a clearly islamist rule or
should he shell the matter to try and
return to the political Arena well
visual party viewers it soon became
clear to him he had to seize any
opportunity that came his way his top
priority had to be to re-establish his
public position after all his role as
Master manager in Istanbul was still in
the popular memory and so in 2001 when
the ban on his political activities was
lifted erdogan founded the justice and
development party his political
spearhead it was a machine that arrived
at the best possible moment at the
beginning of the 21st century turkey was
a country in crisis where news like this
rain 25th February 2001 turkey and
turmoil faced with a financial crisis
which has seen the stock market plummet
and interest rates soar turkey has been
forced to abandon efforts to maintain
the value of its currency the Lira
average annual inflation was hovering
around 60 the unemployment rate was
Rising sharply and the value of the Lira
had plummeted this was the big
opportunity that our protagonist was
looking for it was his moment the
religious agenda was not a priority he
had to present himself as an efficient
manager recalling his more pragmatic
time as mayor of Istanbul that would
give him some social support in a
difficult economic period and also it
would calm the military's misgivings the
result well
take a look
[Music]
the elections were so fragmented that
with only 34.28 of the vote erdogan's
party won an overwhelming absolute
majority his promises of moderation and
reproachment with the European Union
earned him the approval of the military
no one would stand in his way and he
would keep his word his islamist agenda
which shelved he also pushed through a
reform package that accelerated the
privatization of statehood Enterprises
and lowered trade and financial barriers
as a result foreign investments
skyrocketed and turkey experienced an
economic boom as we often say there are
times when a picture is worth a thousand
words well this is one of those cases
take a look
[Music]
after erdogan came to power in March of
2003 foreign investment soared the
measures implemented brought inflation
back to single digits and the national
economy was going from strength to
strength it was what came to be called
the Turkish miracle
and so little by little this political
leader assumed more and more power to
the point that he became strong enough
to put his islamist agenda back on the
table we have told you about this in
several videos that will link for you in
the description below after all who is
going to oppose him he had an
overwhelming social majority he was
responsible for the so-called Turkish
miracle and had gradually co-opted
Managers from All State institutions
including the Army although
not the entire Army
[Music]
a leopard doesn't change at spots
the change of political tone in the
erdogan stage in order to come to power
was somewhat instrumental it did not
change his deepest political convictions
islamism and a very authoritarian view
of
possible for example in 2013 a group of
environmentalists demonstrated against
the demolition of a park in the city of
Istanbul although it was not a
large-scale anti-govern protest the
unconscionable repression outraged
Turkish society and the entire
opposition who used the occasion to
promote huge protests the protest took
place between May and June of the same
year and ended with dozens of people
injures numerous journalists arrested
and strong threats against the media and
not only that during this period
erdogan's Government tried different
kinds of ways to censor the internet for
example it restricted the use of Twitter
26 June 2014 internet censorship in
Turkey since the toxim square protests
began in the summer of 2013 the Turkish
government has been stepping up violence
to crack down on them a new law allows
it to shut down blogs and Twitter
accounts that are inconvenient to it
likewise erdogan gradually redesigned
the institutions to his liking and since
2010 prosecutors close to his party
began a campaign of arrests and
interrogations against senior officers
of the Armed Forces and so on the 15th
July 2016 an attempted coup took place
for many it was the sign of the
military's wearyness for others a
self-coo organized by erdogan himself to
clean house whatever the case the coup
that resulted in 194 dead and more than
1 100 wounded failed and this political
leader took total control let's just say
that the coup gave him the possibility
to overhaul the Army from the top to the
bottom already without the counterweight
of the Army in 2017 erdogan promoted a
constitutional reform that gave the
ruler the power to dissolve parliament
and even appoint half of the
Constitutional Court from that moment on
all indicators of Freedom have fallen in
the country the persecution of opponents
has become frequent and the media has
been gradually tamed if not completely
controlled in most cases to make matters
worse from that moment on foreign
investment began to plummet and erdogan
brought to the table an economic policy
based on Islamic dogmas for instance
against interest rates which has
destroyed the value of the lira in a way
turkey has become more and more like
Russia a country with which despite
being a NATO member it maintains
practically full relations do you want
proof take a look at this 27 April 2023
erdogan and Putin celebrate cooperation
on turkey's first nuclear power plant
nevertheless despite all of this erdogan
has won the elections again check this
out
[Music]
a political earthquake
in February of this year the Turkish
city of gaziantep suffered a terrible
earthquake which killed more than 55
000 people the lack of assistance and
the government's disastrous handling of
the tragedy seemed to open the door to
political change the economy is in Ruins
AKP erdogan's party has depleted
reserves and has vastly expanded pledges
and spending to bolster its patronage
Network I don't know how the country can
avoid economic collapse Darren Ace
mogloo Economist and MIT Professor
what's more most of the opposition that
United under a single candidacy Kamal
khalidstero who became the most favorite
candidate and yet he lost he lost in the
first and the second rounds the Turks
have taken a bet on a political leader
who has shredded civil liberties
provoked an economic crisis owners
clashed with nato in the European Union
and all apparently for one very clear
premise to make turkey a great Islamic
power erdogan has nurtured an unbridled
nationalist sentiment that has now given
him Victory we could say that he's
become a kind of Putin in Turkey once a
moderate politician with a Zeal for
renewing ties the West today he's become
an almost almost kind of nightmare an
ally more uncomfortable than many
enemies the question is how far do you
think erdogan will go will turkey
continue to fall down the slippery slope
of autocracy will this country become
the kind of Russia of the Middle East
you can leave us your answers in the
comments below and let's open a
respectful debate and now if you found
this video interesting don't forget to
like all of us here at visualpolitik And
subscribe if you haven't already done so
all the best I hope you enjoyed the
video
and I'll see you next time
[Music]